[Music]
HF hydrofluoric acid is probably the
most feared chemical compound that there
is the reason it's so feared is that it
is very corrosive it will burn through
human skin even quite a small exposure
on your skin can cause a heart attack
and I really wanted and I still want to
do an experiment with HF all rather I
will kneel to do an experiment for me
with HF
I want to see what happens if we put a
light bulb and electric light bulb the
old not energy-saving salt into a beaker
of HF the reason why it's interesting is
because HF can dissolve glass glass the
chemists friend we use it for test tubes
bottles Kipps apparatus but HF attacks
glass chemically it breaks the silicon
oxygen bonds and forms silicon fluorine
bonds and the compound that dissolves
away in the liquid HF
it was really a bit disappointing the
light bulb sat there glowing peacefully
in the hf the HF has to be in a special
plastic beaker that is cloudy so you
can't see through the side and it just
sat there and Paul Brady had to stand
with a camera watching watching watching
in case something happened because the
reaction produces some heat that's the
reaction of glass with HF and also
because the lightbulb an electric light
bulb is energy inefficient is also
producing heat the water warmed up and
just like when you have a hot bath in a
cold bathroom the walls started misting
up of course the top didn't mist up
because there was a large spotlight
which was producing heat on the top so
the top was warmer so fortunately we
could still see what was going on and
then rather like fishing where there's a
long boring period and then everything
happens quickly suddenly the light bulb
shattered
[Music]
but it didn't shatter in the way you
would expect it was not like firing a
bullet or smashing it with a hammer it
neatly cracked all the way round the
surface exactly where the glass was at
the surface between the liquid and the
air which was something that we hadn't
expected and it produced a really quite
neat cut then as soon as that happened
the bottom part which was very thin
because a lot of it had dissolved
slowly sank away the acid rushed in
dissolved the filament and so the light
went out in a path and then the
electrodes which are much thicker so
they didn't is also fast and which was
still alive started sparking a bit
because of some electrolytic reaction
exactly what's happening I'm not sure
and because were you were using
alternating current it would be quite
complicated because it was switching
between positive negative and then Neil
had stopped clearing up now the clear a
procedure is pretty simple chemistry you
add sodium carbonate and you make sodium
fluoride in principle you could have
used it in toothpaste but it's not of
the right grade for using with humans so
he added sodium carbonate co2 is
released
lots of bubbling and then it's safe
what I think it illustrates yet again
there every time you do an experiment it
will often go in the way you plan but
you learn things because there's always
an unexpected aspect and it was a nice
experiment because it went well didn't
explode but it gave a really nice result